gracias a usted más temprano hablamos o
con la oposición ahí ahora para el otro
lado de las opiniones quiero preguntarle
esta acusación es una amenaza real
contra Piñera sabiendo que los
opositores son minoría en el Senado
usted cree que el presidente está a
salvo
rimas que salvo un proyecto a mí también
República
está mutación pero la verdad que no no
tiene mucho no tiene mucho
saludos estás
bueno justamente cuál podría ser el
impacto de este proceso en el destino
político del país AE dadas las
elecciones que usted ya nos mencionó
elecciones generales el próximo 21 de
noviembre usted cree que esta noticia
golpea al partido
Chile la gente en Chile